je ne m'inquiète pas pour vous autant
vous le dire tout de suite je ne
m'inquiète pas du tout pour vous cette
petite phrase on me l'a répété très
souvent et ça m'a pris des années avant
de la comprendre
si on s'était rencontrés il y a huit ans
quasiment jour pour jour je ne vous
aurais pas du tout raconté la même
histoire qu aujourd'hui ma vie
aujourd'hui elle est géniale
j'ai 47 ans trois enfants qui vont très
bien une maison qui laisse entrer le
soleil la musique d ami précieux
je ne regarde jamais la télé mais je
suis abonné à netflix et puis je voyage
souvent et je rencontre très
régulièrement des gens formidables et
d'ailleurs regardez où je suis ce soir
et puis surtout j'ai une vie
professionnelle qui me passionne en
version courte
je ne fais que des choses que j'aime
avec que des gens qui me plaisent en
version un peu plus longue
je fais partie de la famille des poly
actifs j'ai plusieurs métiers
je dirige à un écosystème d'innovation
dans le monde de l'expertisé comptable
j'enseigne le design de l'expérience
client ftp europe
et puis j'écris je suis auteur et
speaker sur les thèmes du self
leadership et du leadership de
transformation et la transformation
c'est un sujet qui me parle parce que il
ya huit ans c'était retour à la case
départ
récemment divorcée deux adolescentes à
la maison le troisième bébé en route
pôle emploi bientôt 40 ans et un cv de
directrice financière à un métier que
j'ai détesté pendant des années alors
s'adonner oui pardon ça donnait quelque
chose comme ça je cherche un je cherche
un travail mais quelque chose qui n'a
rien à voir avec ce que j'ai fait
jusqu'à présent
et puis oui j'ai bien conscience que je
suis un peu en limite d'âge 40 ans ça
commence à venir
et puisque vous voyez dans mon ventre je
vous le confirme c'est bien un bébé
alors j'ai côtoyé le doubs le monde du
recrutement
et assez rapidement je me suis rendu
compte que le recrutement c'est un peu
comme la banque
c'est un métier d'assureur on ne prête
qu'aux riches et on recrute toujours
sans la moindre imagination
alors j'ai laissé tomber les pistes
classiques et puis j'ai cherché comment
j'allais faire différemment
j'ai pris des petits boulots j'ai
travaillé dans un magasin de peinture
pour les artisans du bâtiment
j'ai géré les affaires d'un chef
d'orchestre japonais
et puis pendant ce temps là je lisais
beaucoup
j'écoutais des conférences je regardais
des vidéos jeux j'écoutais des podcasts
et puis j'ai fait autre chose aussi
c'est que j'ai rencontré beaucoup de
gens le plus de gens possible et à
chaque fois c'est jean il me regarde et
il m'écoutait et à la fin il me disait
toujours la même chose je ne m'inquiète
pas pour vous et je veux dire que
j'étais complètement déconcertée parce
que voilà il n'y avait que moi pour
m'inquiéter de moi même alors je me suis
dit mais peut-être que si ces gens ils
s'inquiètent pas pour toi c'est qu'il
voit quelque chose en toi que tu ne vois
pas ou pas encore et ce serait peut-être
bien de pas tarder à le voir et puis la
deuxième chose qui m'est arrivé à
l'esprit assez rapidement c'est que
j'étais bien tout seul à décider ce que
j'allais faire du reste de ma vie
personne ne le fera à ma place ni le
décider ni l'entreprendre
j'avais 40 ans et en même temps j'en
avais 20 je me pose est exactement la
même question qu'est ce que je vais
faire
et cette question elle ne mettait pas
beaucoup elle avait un côté un peu
désespéré qu'est ce que je vais faire
alors j'ai utilisé une technique que
j'utilisais dans la course à pied chaque
fois que je finissais une course je me
posais cette question je me disais
delphine quelle est la prochaine course
que tu as envie de courir et cette
question je me la pose à ce moment-là je
me dis qu'est ce que tu as envie de
faire non pas qu'est ce que je vais
faire qu'est-ce que je peux faire
comment je vais le faire qu'est ce que
j'ai envie de faire quel est le genre de
vie que tu as envie de vivre maintenant
ça a tout changé j'ai ouvert un outil
merveilleux que j'utilise encore
aujourd'hui j'ai ouvert ma boîte à rêves
comme quand j'étais petite fille et que
je rêvais de
nir claudette parce que j'étais
amoureuse de claude françois alors j'ai
commencé à noter tout tout ce qui me
plaisait tout ce qui m'inspire et tout
ce qui me parlait tout ce qui me toucher
sans savoir ce que j'allais en faire
et puis avec moi j'avais quand même un
très bon matériau de construction ont
passé mon expérience mon vécu
j'ai fait le tri identifié bien ce dont
je ne voulais plus et quand tu sens
clairement ce dont tu ne veux plus en
t'écoute a encore un petit peu n'est pas
très loin de comprendre ce que tu veux
vraiment et finalement en mélangeant ce
que j'avais déjà vécu et ce que j'avais
encore envie de vivre
peu à peu je suis devenu auteur
compositeur et interprète de ma propre
vie et c'est ça le grand réveil c'est
quand tu comprends que le rêve ne
s'oppose pas à la réalité
et quand il la précède abc toute ta vie
qui change
et vous est-ce que vous avez des rêves
ou est-ce que vous les mettez qu'est ce
qui vous inspire aujourd'hui de quoi
vous avez envie est-ce qu'on dessine
encore dans une école d'ingénieurs oui
alors est ce que je peux vous demander
s'il vous plaît de tracer dans votre
esprit un cercle
oui et puis maintenant vous tracez de
diamètre un vertical et horizontal il ce
couple en ans il se coupe en angle droit
oui on a donc maintenant quatre cadrans
en haut à gauche
vous écrivez s'il vous plaît ma boîte à
rêves c'est bien pour ceux pour qui
c'est très clair commencé à les noter
pour ceux qui ne savent pas où c'est pas
sûr écrivait cette question je veux
savoir ce que je veux poser l'intention
et puis peut-être pour tout le monde on
pourrait écrire je veux être heureux et
réussir et dans cet ordre là s'il vous
plaît on sait déjà que le succès ne
conduit pas au bonheur mais que quand on
est heureux on réussit beaucoup mieux
n'attendez pas
est ce que je peux vous demander
maintenant de vous lever s'il vous plaît
et simplement de faire avec moi sommes
pas même un tout petit peu en avant même
un tout petit peu en avant reprenez vos
stylos et écrivait en haut de votre
cercle toutes les courses commencent
toujours par un premier pas oui ok merci
vous pouvez vous asseoir
ben voilà vous avez fait le plus
difficile
vous venez d'éprouver les deux premiers
temps de toutes les courses se sentir
inspiré et oser démarrer et voici la
matrice des quatre temps qui se dessine
et vous l'avez bien compris le premier
temps de toutes les courses et le temps
de l'inspirent
le temps du rêve le temps du désir c'est
être très clair sur qu'est ce qui me
fait envie de quoi j'ai envie pourquoi
j'en ai envie qu elle est mon intention
et puis régulièrement extirper de ta
boîte à rêves
un rêve et le planter dans ta réalité
c'est le moment de l'audace jose je me
lance
et à ce moment là c'est monsieur walt
disney qui nous vient en aide
connaissez vous la différence entre un
rêve et un projet non une date
je passe en mode projet grâce à mon
calendrier
mon agenda mon deuxième outil de travail
avec ma boîte à rêves et pendant le
deuxième temps je me prépare exactement
comme dans une course à pied je mobilise
mon attention
je définis mes objectifs je calibre mon
entraînement en fonction des objectifs
que je me suis fixé
je commence à activer un club de
supporters
et puis je n'oublie pas je me prépare à
réussir et le jour j je suis là bien
alignés sur la ligne de départ
je suis prête à courir à réaliser à
entrer dans l'action
après
ikea expérimentés et une action inspiré
et mille fois plus puissante qu'une
action qui ne l'est pas chaque fois que
je m'engage je gagne chaque fois que je
finis je franchis une finish line je
gagne aussi j'ai appris j'ai vécu j'ai
expérimenté je me suis enrichi
sénèque disait ce que nous devons
apprendre à faire nous l'apprenons en le
faisant
alors moi j'aime bien dire que c'est en
courant qu'on apprend à courir pain
restant sur le bord c'est en vivant
qu'on apprend à vivre c'est seule
l'expérience enseigne à condition de ne
pas oublier de transformer son
expérience en apprentissage et c'est
tout l'objet du quatrième temps de la
course un temps souvent oublié et c'est
pourtant le vrai temps de la
transformation
j rêver j'ai osé je me suis préparé j'ai
couru et maintenant je récupère alors
déjà je me fais le site
quelles que soient mes résultats parce
que j'ai couru j'ai osé et puis je dis
merci merci pour l'expérience vécue
et puis je vais me poser ses questions
et maintenant qu'est ce que j'ai appris
sur moi sur les autres que j'ai croisés
sur le monde
et qu'est ce que je vais en faire
comment je m'en sers pour préparer ma
prochaine course et cette matrice des
quatre temps ce qui est génial c'est que
on peut s'en servir pour tous alors
quand je suis en train de courir et ben
c'est toujours la même chose j'ai envie
de m'inscrire à une course je m'inscris
avant d'être prête ensuite je m'entraîne
ensuite je coure ensuite je récupère
mais ça marche aussi pour gérer mon
organisation du temps du temps de vie
mon organisation personnelle j'ai ma
boîte à rêves
régulièrement je le transforme en projet
c'est mon agenda
tous les ans je réalise un certain
nombre de choses et puis ensuite quand
tout va bien ça passe sur instagram
quand je prépare une conférence ou quand
j'écris un livre comment je fais je peur
de la fin tient avec quoi j'ai envie de
vous laisser et puis je remonte à mon
intention pourquoi je fais ça et ensuite
seulement je réfléchisse
le format quel est le meilleur format
qui va servir mon intention et ensuite
seulement le contenu
quand je dirige la société le groupe que
je dirige
voilà je suis en situation de leadership
quel est le sens de notre action
ensuite seulement quels sont les projets
que nous entreprenons et sont-ils aligné
sur le sens et bien après un moment
donné il faut produire il faut réaliser
et le 4e temps vous l'avez compris c'est
bien sûr le temps du bilan mais pas que
c'est aussi le temps du feedback
c'est le temps de l'apprentissage c'est
ce que j'appelle l'entreprise
apprenantes entreprenante
vous connaissez probablement simon sinek
start oui fouilles ben voilà dans la
matrice on le met en mouvement
le premier temps c'est le pourquoi
ensuite le raul au wat et simon si je
peux me permettre
on peut boucler avec so what pour
continuer à tourner et ne pas arrêter
d'évoluer et puis vous savez toutes les
applications les interfaces digital ça
fonctionne de la même façon je veux
monter ma start up j'ai une idée
d'application
j'ai plein d'idées de fonctionnalités je
les mets dans un backlog et puis un
moment donné il faut bien démarrer je ne
peux pas tout faire
alors je vais créer un petit lot de
fonctionnalités et puis je vais les
transporter dans un backlog de sprint et
ensuite on va les réaliser en mode
accéléré de quelques jours à quelques
semaines
nous réalisons produits le mvp et puis
ensuite on fait quoi quatrième temps en
recettes test and learn on teste et on
apprend et puis on corrige les bugs
aussi et c'est quoi les bugs dans la
méthode des quatre temps alors plusieurs
types de bugs
d'une certaine façon chaque fois que
j'oublie de nourrir un des quatre temps
ça se passe moins bien il ya des gens
qui rêvent beaucoup mais qui passe très
peu à l'action la procrastination ya des
gens qui courent beaucoup mais un moment
donné il courez courez courez ils savent
plus pourquoi il court et ça c'est
compliqué de courir quand tu sais pas
pourquoi tu cours régulièrement je vous
invite à vous invite à vous poser cette
question est-ce que je rêve à c est ce
que j'ose suffisamment
c'est ce que j'entreprends suffisamment
est-ce que je pratique suffisamment
est-ce que j'expérimente suffisamment et
puis le dernier qui est aussi très
important est ce que je prend
suffisamment de temps pour moi de temps
pour penser à ce que j'ai fait ce que
j'ai encore envie de faire
et globalement si vous posez ces quatre
questions vous allez garder un équilibre
autres bugs possible le court circuit le
court-circuit par exemple j'oublie le
quatrième temps j'oublie d'apprendre je
cours je cours je cours je cours
toujours la même façon je vis toujours
la même chose
einstein disait la folie pour l'homme
c'est de penser qu une même cause va
entraîner un effet différent l'histoire
sans fin
vous la voyez donc on peut oublier le
quatrième temps puis un autre bug aussi
que j'aime beaucoup quand on oublie le
deuxième temps je passe du temps à
autant 3 je vous donne un exemple mon
fils tommy il adore les pokémon alors
qu'est-ce qui se passe
tommy veut des pokémon maman achète des
pokémon tommy vos des pokémon maman
achète des pokémon satisfaction 0
plaisir 0 pourquoi il ya deux raisons la
première raison c'est que tommy n'est
pas l'auteur de sa réalisation il n'est
pas l'auteur de toute la boucle je peux
lui faire plaisir et je ne peux pas le
rendre heureux
faut arrêter avec cette idée qu'on peut
rendre les autres heureux ça marche pas
comme ça et puis la deuxième raison à
écouter elle existe dans la chanson on
m'a trop donné bien avant l'envi j'ai
oublié les rêves et les mercis toutes
ces choses qu'on m'avait je sais plus et
des mois un petit peu on m'a trop donné
bien avant l'envi j'ai oublié les rêves
et les mercis toutes ces choses qui
avaient un prix qui font envie de vivre
et le désir et le plaisir aussi
ouais qu'on me donne l'envié l'envié
d'avoir envie qu'on rallume ma vie vous
l'entendez maintenant quand on oublie le
temps de il ya juste une petite chose
avec laquelle je suis pas tout à fait
d'accord c'est que y'a personne qui peut
allumer ta vie à ta place
la lumière elle doit venir de
l'intérieur
pire et vous remplissez vos boîtes à
rêves ouais et puis peut-être pour
terminer il ya deux courses dans la vie
qui sont extrêmement singulière de
course pour lesquels on oublie trop
souvent de nourrir chacun des quatre
temps de course pour lesquelles nous
confondons aisément la ligne d'arrivée
avec la ligne de départ un jour tu auras
envie d'un enfant tu vas le désirez vous
allez le préparer pendant neuf mois à
peu près l'enfant va arriver ce jour là
vous avez pensé que vous êtes arrivé ça
vient juste de démarrer un jour tu auras
envie de vivre l'aventuré du couple vous
allez vous désirez vous allez vous
préparez vous allez vous marier
peut-être et ce jour là vous allez
penser que vous êtes arrivé là aussi ça
vient juste de démarrer
et puis avant ça il ya sept filles où ce
garçon qui te plaît beaucoup
alors vous allez vous désirez vous
parlez aux et la rencontre prendre le
temps de la découverte
vous touchez etc bref un jour enfin la
première nuit d'amour et là tu vas
penser que tu es ce que tu a conclu ça
va pas non ça vient juste de démarrer
peut-être mais je voulais dit je ne
m'inquiète pas pour vous je ne
m'inquiète pas du tout pour vous merci
[Applaudissements]